the interesting thing about your Ted
talk to go to a dark topic
um
what happened when I walked off stage
no what happened when you walked off
station found out that I had a brain
tumor
was that not where you're going there's
nothing else dark about my yeah well yes
um
uh I thought you knew through the Ted
Talk you found out right after I mean
the reason that I found out was partly
because of the Ted talk because my mom
came into town to be there for it
and my right eyelid was swollen and it
kind of been swelling over a while and I
even gotten comments about it on my
YouTube channel and I thought it was
allergies because I was like oh it's
just pollen allergies it's just
affecting my one eye because maybe I
sleep mostly on that side I don't know
and my mom came into
um
the states and then Vancouver for my TED
talk and she's like Simone you have to
like have a scan or see what's up like
we have to go to the doctor and she
really pushed me to do it because I was
like I'm fine
um
and I had an MRI scan
on like 5 p.m on a Friday night my
boyfriend at the time was there and
I remember like halfway through an MRI
scan they kind of pull you out and they
put inject contrast fluid
or this like thing that yeah just gives
them another type of scan and the nurse
looked at me in this way and was like
how long have you had symptoms for and
that's what I knew that they'd found
something and then they like shove you
back into the machine for another 20
minutes and my ex was just seeing like
them like zooming in and out of my scans
and there was like this obviously
something that just looked wrong in
there and they sent me to the ER and I
found out that I had
a brain tumor the size of a golf ball
that probably been grown since I was a
teenager so it's been growing over like
10 15 years
and yeah I had surgery to remove it and
then it kept on growing the parts that
they couldn't remove and I went through
radiation treatment so that was like
two years that just
was kind of dedicated to just getting
better and getting back to where I am
now and I remember like I was so stoked
about 2020 because I was like this is
the first year that I'm not held back by
my health and I'm like finally going to
be able to do everything on feathered
and then the pandemic happens and you're
kind of it's like okay just in the back
seat of what's happening and things that
are out of my control again
in your public you made a couple of
videos about yeah about it I have a
brain tumor my brain tumors back
you kind of you know you name your tumor
Brian you kind of make it a
light-hearted thing
but you don't reveal much of the
darkness
but were you scared or some low plants
of of course I was of course I was
scared
I mean it's terrifying it's like
and also when it's in your brain like
you know I was like take any other part
of me but don't take my brain
um no it's this unfathomable thing that
happens and you're like I'm healthy I've
had how could this possibly be a brain
tumor like my eye is swollen like
there's nothing there I haven't had any
seizures I haven't had any cognitive
issues I haven't had any headaches even
like how is that even possible
um so you go through a lot of different
stages of just trying to understand what
it is and I think I remember
being hit like right as I found out when
we're in like an Uber poor Uber driver
from where I had my MRI scanned to the
ER where they sent me
and I was really both really grateful
that I've gotten so much more out of
life than I ever thought I would like
I've had a hell of a life and even if it
would have ended really early I would
have done so much more than I ever
thought but I was also really really sad
that I hadn't had kids yet like that was
my big grief of like [__] I haven't had
had time to have kids yet
um but no it's terrifying I mean the
prospect of somebody cutting up your
head
like that's
terrifying but it honestly
wasn't as bad as I thought it was gonna
be what about the radiation treatment
what are some things that
you know people should you learned about
it about the process and about yourself
through that the the people might be
interested about I think
surgery was both harder and easier than
radiation treatment because it was it
was harder because it was
so much more intense and it's such a
dramatic thing like going to the
hospital that morning and being like
I don't know and you feel so awful when
you wake up and but then the recovery
from it was pretty linear like almost
every week I would get a little bit
better the thing about radiation is that
it was not linear at all and it kind of
drained me in this weird like it was so
hard to predict and also they put me on
these um
I spent months feeling like I was high
out of my mind
and I couldn't process reality in a way
that I normally would like everything
just felt off like I felt yeah I felt
like I was high on drugs and I kept on
asking my doctors what was going on and
they're like no I don't know don't think
it's anything related
and
I was on this Alzheimer's medicine that
they put you on to prevent dementia from
radiation treatment like kind of as a
preventative and I found all these
subreddits of people using that
Alzheimer's medicine to get high and
people be like oh my God bro like 20
milligrams yesterday and I was high out
of my mind and I'm like I'm on 30
milligrams a day like of course it feels
weird and that was honestly one of the
scariest parts of it because that was
the first time where I felt like it
genuinely affected my way of processing
reality and yeah I was so relieved when
I found out that that was what was
causing it because I felt like I was
going crazy but even after surgery like
I woke up and I felt like myself like
everything was I got no brain injury so
obviously this is like my experience
from somebody who came out of it pretty
unscathed who didn't get any brain
injuries and didn't have to do any of
that recovery it's more just the
recovery from like the physical act of
somebody cutting your skull open and
taking a large chunk out did you
research all the things that can go
wrong no brain surgery no I honestly am
I'm a bit surprised by how I acted
pausing for you to pour
[Laughter]
you're welcome editors
I see that commercial
this is like a work injury from being a
YouTuber I saw like freeze if there's
audio that comes in
ah yeah yeah sponsored by tap water
um I was surprised by
how little I was willing to
think critically about what my doctors
told me to do
like I very early on I I the neurologist
that I worked with
he was the one who was on call at the ER
the day where I came in and he was the
one who ended up doing my surgery and he
kind of became like my rock in this and
I just 100 trusted him and he turned out
to be an amazing doctor and like did a
great job and was just like a
so I got so so lucky but I remember my
mom being like Oh but we should like
talk about second opinions and like we
should try to do more research and I was
like so unwilling to do that because
opening up to the idea that
there are
multiple ways or multiple things that
might be right or wrong was so
terrifying like I wanted there to just
be like no this is the only option this
is what we need to do
and if I started questioning that then I
don't know if I would have been able to
go through with it so yeah it was
estranged I just really wanted to trust
the doctors that I worked with and I was
very scared to question them in any way
how did that process change your
relationship with death
are you afraid of death
to ponder your mortality yeah I think it
took away a part of Youth
for me like the Innocence yeah I mean
you kind of think of terrible things as
something that happens to other people
and death and illness
um so I think it kind of fast tracked
that for me
but it mostly changed my relationship to
life
it changed it's made me so much more
gentle with myself like going through
illness
it forces you to redefine what it means
to be good and before being good had
been pushing myself really hard it had
been working and
I don't know just just being really hard
with myself and disciplined and when
you're healing from something being good
is listening to your body it's resting
it's like really being in tune with what
your health where your health is at and
I think that is something that's kind of
stuck with me since then I'm like so
much more gentle and delicate with
myself
and with others
I think it definitely it's like when
you're young and healthy it's really
hard to yeah
um
know what it feels like to be ill and I
remember
you know you like go to yoga class and
you'd be like oh my God this is too slow
like I wanted to be I have so much more
energy like I need to and when I was
recovering from my brain surgery there
was this yoga studio nearby my house and
they had uh yoga for seniors and I was
so stoked because I was like oh this is
the yoga class I'll be able to take yeah
and I think that was really eye-opening
of just like there's no you kind of
imagine that it's just like oh just push
yourself harder but no that's not it
with age or sickness or it's just you've
got to be so gentle with yourself and
you have to
cater to people where they're at
yeah just uh appreciation of this like
biological vehicle you get and you
should take care of it being sick
it's awful and I really I'm really
motivated to
postpone that for as much as I can and
also I was so tremendously grateful when
I got ill that I felt like I had so much
to take from like I had so many energy
arrested Wars I'd spent my life taking
pretty decent care of my body and like
exercising and eating well and like not
wrecking my body in any way and I felt
like
this was the first time where that was
so critical and I felt like my body was
ready for it you know
I thought you're gonna go the other way
like um you can you can take care of
your body all you want it's
um bad stuff happened so you should you
should go on drug binges and go wild and
do crazy things and I mean I also had
that that
I [__] floss every day how do I have
a brain tumor I've been good like why
does this happen to me but more so it
was like my body was so resilient and
ready for it and
um I was I was really really proud of it
it's amazing that the human body is able
to recover from even the harshest things
yeah it's it's wild and my brain so
after
after surgery because yeah I had to
brain tumor the size of a golf ball kind
of behind my right eye and after brain
surgery you kind of just have this big
hole in your head like this void and
usually your brain stays that way like
it retains the shape even after the
brain tumor is gone but for some reason
my brain was feeling really ambitious
and it has completely flopped back and I
have almost like a normal looking brain
now where doctors are like oh we would
almost not be able to tell that you had
one
um so yeah that just blew my mind to be
like when did it was that why I had all
those headaches yeah for surgery it's
just my brain being like
trying yeah